from the six degrees of separation and
the stirring woman bad boys will
the category is visual effects and man
look the branch was really tough on
themselves this year you know there's
only two nominations
now the first nominee for Best Visual
Effects is Apollo 13 now the real story
of Apollo 13 took place in outer space
where there is no gravity for the movie
version nominees Robert legato Michael
Caine for Lesley occur and Matt Sweeney
built sets inside a que 135 airplane
used a trained astronauts Apollo 13 is
the first film to ever be shot in true
weightless conditions these remarkable
scenes were accomplished by flying way
up into the stratosphere and putting the
plane into a steep dive go the second
nominee for Best Visual Effects is babe
now what happens when you take a dog a
duck a cat see sheep look at the pork
and put them in the hands with a visual
effects team from babe well nominees
Scottie Anderson Charles Gibson Neal
Scanlan and John Cox were they've never
revealed their secrets so let's just
enjoy their amazing artistry shall we
and the Oscar goes to Scottie Anderson
Charles Gibson Neal Scanlan John Cox for
babe
like to thank the membership for
realizing that the babe was a visual
effects film animals don't really talk
and to George Miller and Chris Newton's
vision a world where animals have as
much humanity and personality as humans
do to Carl Miller whose amazing animal
action just was an inspiration to us
tamarcus Darcy - John freaking and -
teaming Rhythm & Hues I'd like to thank
John Stevenson and everybody there
Henson Creature Shop above all I'd like
to thank my crew their brilliance and
dedication made this their award - I'd
also like to thank you the Academy I'd
like to thank Greg McKay Chris chilly
Matt ward my loyal crew my mom and my
family Hey - Chris Noonan this is for
you your friends and your friendship
thanks a lot
how's Beck guys think about Bruce
Springsteen you know you wrote the music
for dead man walking and Philadelphia
they sort of same boss you know I think
you should lighten up a little bit maybe
do a tune face Venturi you know
something two reasons nobody left
leaving Las Vegas were its stars both
nominated for Oscars tonight she got to
play a fragile call girl on the strip a
field day for any actress
I'm not gonna say it and he got every
actors role an agent who was drinking
himself to death
here are the fun couple of the year
Elizabeth Shue and Nicolas Cage
the competitive category for documentary
film joined Oscars army in wartime 1941
that year the National Film Board of
Canada picked up the prize for
Churchill's Island a daring look at how
England fought off the threat of Nazi
invasions ever since then documentary
filmmakers have used 101 ways to cut
corners and still deliver powerful
messages this year for best achievement
in documentary Short subject the
nominees are Jim dine a self-portrait on
the walls
Nancy dine and Richard Stilwell the
living see Greg MacGillivray and Alec
Laura Moore never give up the 20th
century Odyssey of Herbert zippered
Terry Sanders and Frieda Lee mock one
survivor remembers Kerry and solace the
shadow of hate Charles Elie Guggenheim